in addition to using these weapons
against Iran Saddam also decides to use
them against the Kurds his own citizens
living in the mountains of northern Iraq
Saddam considers the Kurds his enemies
their goal is to be granted independence
from his country the Kurds have their
own political parties and their own
militia the Peshmerga in 1987 Saddam
appoints his cousin Ali Hassan al-majid
to execute a military campaign called
the on fall on fall is Arabic for the
spoils the term refers to a book in the
Quran that proclaims the spoils of war
belong to Allah and his messengers in an
audiotape
ali hassan al-majid discusses his plans
for the kurds with fellow officers in
northern Iraq
a year later in February 1988 the Iraqi
army begins the on fall campaign Saddam
believes it will solve his Kurdish
problem for the next six months al Majid
orders the Iraqi Air Force to drop
mustard gas and nerve agents on the
civilian population for this he becomes
known among Iraqis as chemical ally
these people show the visible signs of
mustard gas skin burns and blistering
many suffer temporary or permanent
blindness internally the gas damages the
respiratory tract bringing a slow and
painful death Saddam also used nerve
agents such as sarin it causes a wide
range of symptoms including convulsions
vomiting and death during the campaign
the chemicals drive the Kurds away from
their villages once out in the open the
Iraqi military captures them and takes
them to prison camps hundreds of
thousands of Kurds are carted away the
army bulldozes their villages to ensure
that they cannot return and they went in
and removed thousands and thousands of
people bulldoze the entire villages
mosques houses farms rape the land kill
the animals strip the area of crops and
remove the entire population from that
area when they come in this village they
killed the old women and old men and
they took the young girls and they steal
everything and they what they do they
damage the village all of them they
don't live nothing they don't live the
animal - they kill the animal